usako visa what SpaceX's first moon
tourist the 43 year old yuusaku Misawa
is an online retail tycoon in Japan
he's also controversial often portrayed
negatively in Japanese media for
flaunting his wealth on social media and
he likes to dabble
he's a punk rock drummer turned
entrepreneur Billina turned art
collector turned moon tourist and a
secret to success
worthless this is how use a kumazawa
made billions by dodging cultural norms
in Japan grabbing publicity through
outrageous purchases and stunts Mizell
was recent purchase but an international
attention for the first time a
round-trip ticket to the moon on
SpaceX's new rocket called starship
which is being designed to colonize Mars
[Music]
I think the bravest person and most
wanting to do so although he wouldn't
disclose the prices paying for the ride
Elon Musk said you Suk hoon was funding
a material percentage of starships
estimated 5 billion dollar development
cost at some point he began to talk with
Elon Musk about traveling to outer space
we don't know the exact timeline but you
know he is the first passenger she would
be the first private citizen to fly
dubbed the damn moon project music who
says he will take artists and musicians
of his choice to in his words inspire
world peace I do think this is a really
big publicity stunt for those oh so zone
is you Zack who's online clothing
company it's what made him a billionaire
in his mid thirties my father said
publicly that he wants to become one of
the top brands globally he expected to
quintuple his market cap right now 50
billion dollars within 10 years and a
lot of that would be driven by global
expansion these ambitious plans are in
contrast to his humble upbringing his
dad was an accountant and his mum a
housewife
in a country known for conformity
yuusaku Misawa has always sought to
stand out it started in high school
where he saw gloomy white collared
workers called salaryman in Japan
commuting to work donut a second
estimate a terrazzo need zucchini little
meaty
macoco chances at okra lanka today
originally not at all
Yuka with us he skipped college spent
time in California and later joined a
punk rock band called
switch style which became popular within
Japan when why he became a drummer he
said it's not so much that he loved
playing on the drums it was just easier
to join a band as a drummer because
drummers were in higher demand you got
to start to see a pattern emerge that
he's a commercially kind of
transactionally driven person even from
an early age shortly after joining the
band
he started his companies start today
which sold imported records by
mail-order in Japan start today became
quite successful selling records and
then moved on into clothes you sucker
was able to choose good music and good
clothes to sell online and which is how
the business began to take off the
online clothing website called Zozo town
is now Japan's go-to site for online
fashion shopping in 2010 when profits
started to really really go up and the
company was approaching a billion dollar
market cap he came out to an earnings
press conference in front of analysts
and investors and he was dressed like a
giant mushroom it was one of his first
time to kind of grab spotlight and his
attention grabbing stunts have been
getting increasingly controversial over
the past years his social media feeds a
full of French wines private jets
supercars a Pablo Picasso painting he
purchased and record-breaking works from
American street artist jean-michel
Basquiat
the local media here is pretty
relentless in how they attack him they
say that he shows off his money he
stands for all the things that
traditional Japanese values do not stand
for younger people generally love them
they like someone who's open they like
that he's extremely
active on social media misako american
arrow the Pokeno capacitive mosquito
someday will go up painless yuusaku said
he plans to make Zozo a leading global
clothing brand within a decade by
revolutionising how people buy clothes
online beginning with this year's debut
of a body measuring outfit called the
Zozo suit the Zozo suit has allowed my
seller to collect the measurements of
millions of people he says he can now
predict the perfect clothing size for
their sex age height and weight he plans
to use that to become a world leading
clothing brand I mean not even Amazon
has anything like this and there's a
global e-commerce leader and what better
way to promote it then to jump off Elon
Musk's rocket around the moon that
everyone in the world knows who you are
kumazawa in order to stay ahead of the
curve Zozo town is offering tech talent
salaries of up to 100 million yen which
is an unusual move in Japan where
workers often take lower pay in exchange
for secure employment
he's also encouraging employees to
condense work and spend more time
outside the office pursuing all kinds of
intellectual and artistic listens I
think you Doug whose secret is that he
knows what people want weather Zozo
town's new technology revolutionizes the
way we shop online or not the world will
have his eyes on you exactly and Elon
Musk in 2023 which is the estimated
travel date for the first-ever tourist
trip to the moon as far as me going I'm
not sure every will but maybe what be on
it
you
[Applause]
[Music]